épidémie oblige les gestes barrières
sont de rigueur au musée de la ville de
saint quentin en yvelines
mais l'établissement reçoit à nouveau
des visiteurs depuis quinze jours sur le
mois de juin ça a été très très calme
les gens sont revenus doucement un peu
pour voir aussi ce qui avait été mis en
place et puis je pense qu'il y avait
d'autres priorités ce qui est bien ce
qui est bien normal
et puis là on voit là ils reviennent on
les voit revenir ce mois de juillet on
sent que c'est ya un vrai retour à la
normale on voit que les gestes barrières
sont bien respectées dans musée et puis
voilà on est sur une fréquentation qui
nous permet d'assouplir un petit peu
donc on va avoir une jauge limitée à 15
personnes dans les espaces du musée et
on a supprimé le sens de circulation
mais maintenu par contre l'obligation du
port du masque et la distanciation physx
une période de pause forcée mise à
profit par les équipes programmation
repenser création de visites virtuelles
et d'un été très culturel l'histoire de
saint quentin en yvelines se transmet
cet été en visites extérieures et
également des visites à vélo qui sont
des formules qui sont très chouette
l'été et faut dire que saint quentin en
yvelines offre une quantité de sentiers
de chemin qu'on peut utiliser un vélo et
qui permettent vraiment de re découvrir
ce territoire autrement et souvent les
gens sont vraiment surpris de ce dont on
peut parcourir l'ensemble du territoire
la rentrée aussi sera animé la nuit des
musées décalé au 14 novembre